before pier's dramatic departure from
his show he invited on a certain
polarizing guest megan's estranged
father thomas markle
this is actually the first time i've
heard her speak in
four years in this unaired oprah clip
megan says they stopped talking after he
lied about taking part in a series of
staged
paparazzi photos leading up to the 2018
wedding
did it feel like betrayal when you found
out your father was
working with the tabloids if we're gonna
use the word betrayal
it's because we called my dad and i
asked him
and he said no absolutely not
and that for me has really resonated
especially now as a mother
i can't imagine doing anything to
intentionally cause pain to my child
why weren't you honest with her about
what can i tell my side now
of course you can i denied it yes
i wish i hadn't done the whole thing but
no one took any time to
protect any member of our family i was
left out to dry
and and in spite of all that i still
apologize i was apologizing today again
and then came the butt but i've never
played naked pool
and i've never dressed up like hitler
criticism has surfaced that megan and
harry should have expected
to lose a degree of privacy in all this
megan shut that down
if you're at work and you have a
photograph of your child on your desk
and your co-worker says oh my gosh can i
see all the pictures of your child
you go no this is the picture i'm
comfortable sharing with you
you know what i'm just gonna hide in the
bushes and take pictures into your
backyard
because you shared one image with me
this next level royal crisis
has many fans of the crown begging for
this to be written into
an upcoming season do you all watch the
ground
i've watched some of it but that's not
going to happen the creator has a
20-year rule to truly understand the
events that have taken place
but rest assured late night has it
covered i
am here for it
concerns and conversations about how
dark his skin might be when he's born
what i agree what i'm gonna go on a limb
here and say that there is a possibility
just a possibility mind you
that this medieval selective breeding
program might be
racist
and you're not going to tell me who had
the conversation
i remember that day in windsor it was
magical when harry and megan got married
and i
remember thinking that the world had
finally shifted that we were moving
forward
but now we know that the fairy tale was
actually the beginning of a very long
and painful nightmare thankfully they
have had a chance to speak their truth
and move on to the other
you